-My first guest
is a Grammy-winning artist
with a brand-new single out.
It is awesome.
It's called
"Let Me Reintroduce Myself."
It went straight to number one.
Here she is -- Gwen Stefani!
Aw, Come on!
-Whoo!
-Yay!
-Gwen --
-I can't believe I'm back.
-I love it. Dude,
I want you back every week.
-Aww, thank you.
-I don't know
if you remember this.
A few years ago,
you gave me a suggestion
for my girls
for Christmas morning to --
-Yes.
-To put Christmas wrapping
on the doorway on their way
into the tree
so that they rip it open
and then see the presents.
Is that right?
-But obviously Santa
and the elves do that.
You have to e-mail him,
and then he does that,
if you request it, yep?
-So I requested it.
I talked to Santa.
Santa put on the paper on the --
wrapped the door so beautifully.
And I was, like --
Oh, it was so cool.
I couldn't believe it.
I was in shock when I woke up.
In the morning.
And I go down to videotape
on the other side,
because I want my girls
to run in and rip --
But there's just such --
I mean, you have boys,
so you --
I have girls, and they came in,
and they politely just pushed it
open like it's a curtain.
-No!
-Yeah, and it was such a --
-They didn't crash through it?
-They're so polite.
They just pushed
like it was a curtain.
And they're so excited
'cause Santa came.
But they didn't rip it
or anything.
It's like, "I have to take
a picture and send it to Gwen,"
because it's the best idea,
honestly,
and everyone should ask Santa
if they can do this.
But I ended up cutting a hole
in the Christmas wrapping,
and just sticking my daughter's
head in the doorway.
-Oh, my God!
[ Both laugh ]
-Because she wouldn't rip it.
-That is so cute.
-That's the only rip
is that right there.
They just pushed it open.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Well, I feel like you have
to take that same picture now
every single year,
'cause that's what we do.
We always have a picture,
like, in front of the paper.
And we were at a new house.
We moved.
So it was, like,
a really big deal this year
'cause we didn't know, like,
where Santa was gonna actually
wrap the opening 'cause it's,
like, a really big opening.
-Oh, my goodness.
-And ours was crashed through
by, like, teenager
and, like, littles.
It was fun.
-I want to congratulate you
because you and Blake Shelton
are engaged!
Come on!
-Yay!
-That's what I'm talking about.
I love it.
I have questions.
How did Blake propose?
Did he have it all planned out?
What was it like?
-Well, um, it was actually
pretty magical.
And wasn't expecting it at the
moment that it happened at all.
Didn't have any idea.
Nobody knew.
I think he had told my dad
on my birthday
about two weeks earlier.
And I got to tell you, like,
I was sort of like,
"What's happening with us?"
Like, it was kind of in my mind,
"Like, we've been together
a long time now.
Like, what's going on?"
I was in that place in my head.
And we also had this trip
planned to come on Oklahoma,
and it was one of those COVID
kind of, like, not a fight,
but it was like, "Maybe we
should just cancel the trip."
Like, "This is getting too hard.
Like, it's not gonna --"
Everybody has to get tested,
and everyone was on edge,
'cause we were gonna meet up
with his sister
and brother-in-law
and their family.
And everything, all the plans,
you can't make plans anymore.
So, anyways, we were this close
to, like, canceling the trip.
And we ended up
making it all happen.
And we were all here
at the ranch,
and, basically, it happened.
But it was like everybody was
trying to make it not happen
'cause nobody knew
it was gonna happen.
And Blake, meanwhile,
had this ring, like, I guess,
in the side of his, like, truck.
And when I say
"the side of his truck,"
like, his truck is disgusting.
It is like things falling out,
like, equipment,
like total rugged man stuff.
-Yeah.
Like, mud, you know?
-He got mad at me that
there's no mud on my truck.
He goes, "Jimmy, don't ever
show me that truck."
'Cause I showed him a picture
of my truck, and it was like --
There's not even any --
"I can't even look at it.
There's no mud on that truck.
You have to use that."
He was so disappointed.
-I know.
-So I can imagine
what his truck looks like.
It's a real ranch truck.
-Yes.
And there's, like,
a lot of junk in it and dirt.
And so the fact
that the ring was, like,
in the side of the door --
And, like, you're driving
through trees and stuff.
Like, it could just like
fall out at any point.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Anyways, it was pretty magical.
And my brother was trying to
cook like a hobo stew at home,
so he was like,
"We gotta get back!
It's gonna burn!"
And my son was, like,
"I gotta go to the bathroom!"
And, like,
nobody wanted to be there.
Anyways, out of nowhere,
he just has this ring
that's, like,
in a cabinet when I opened it.
He's like,
"Oh, get the fire starter,"
and I, like, open the cabinet,
and there's this ring there.
And I'm like,
"Are you serious?!"
[ Chuckles ]
It was pretty, like, "What?!"
And we both start bawling,
and everyone was in shock.
There was no video.
My sister-in-law-to-be
was there, and she just started,
like, shooting off pictures,
and that's the shot
that we put out.
It was just a random picture.
So, it is pretty exciting.
-It's kind of fun
not having it on video.
-We have no plans
because of the pandemic.
It's like, "Blake, why couldn't
you have done it before?
Now we can't have a wedding
with the pandemic."
-[ Laughing ]
-Sitting around going, "Okay."
Drag it out more.
-You guys are so famous,
it was actually good news
for the world,
'cause we all needed -- any good
news, and we'll take it.
And I was like, "Yes!"
We all cheered.
So just know it was awesome.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
Thank you so much.
-And tell Blake
he's a hopeless romantic.
I've got to talk to him
about that truck move.
Let's talk about
"Let Me Reintroduce Myself."
Came out last month,
went straight to number one.
Congrats on this.
-Thank you.
-This is the perfect song,
by the way.
-Thank you, thank you.
-And the video,
how'd you come up with the idea
to do all of your looks?
-Well, this is --
Basically, it wasn't my idea.
I had --
We were doing that song,
"Happy Anywhere," me and Blake.
And we were here
in the pandemic, stuck,
quarantined at the ranch,
so we didn't get a chance
to do, like, a real video.
My brother happened to be here,
and so we kind of
made the video that we made.
But my original idea
for that video was,
"You be Blake from the '90s,
like with a mullet,
and I'll be me,
the 'Just a Girl' me,
and we could, like, be the
different versions of us
in this video,
like, happy anywhere.
Like, this weird couple
that doesn't make any sense,
but we do.
-Ah.
-And he was not into it.
But we could've never done it
anyways because we were
stuck here at the ranch.
Anyways, Blake was the one
that said, "You know, that song,
'Let Me Reintroduce Myself,'
that's a hit," or whatever.
And because he has had like
27 number-one radio hits,
and he's been on "The Voice"
for 20 seasons picking songs
and being around music,
I trust him in that.
And he was the one who said,
"You should, like --"
He called me
driving to the airport
and was like,
"You should dress up as you
in all your old looks
and do this video."
And I was, like, "Whoa. That's
actually a really good idea."
-I mean,
look at all these looks.
It's genius.
Gwen, I'm telling you,
it was just --
-Wow.
-I just love
that you did all this.
It's so fantastic.
-It was so much work.
It was so fun, though,
but it was really trippy,
because, like,
you would basically --
It'd be in the original look
of what I was back then,
and it brought back
so many memories.
And I never thought,
when I was doing those looks,
that I would be basically
a Halloween costume
to other people.
-[ Laughs ]
Like, that was actually
how I dressed,
not because anyone told me to,
but that was like --
I had that polka-dot dress
in my closet forever.
And just the fact that
they became so recognizable,
it was really fun to revisit it.
And it was just
a really fun way to come back.
-Is there an album on the way,
or is this just a tease?
-Yes, of course.
-There is?
-I mean, that was --
I mean, at first,
I didn't know
if I would do an album or not.
But I have all these songs,
and I think that even, like,
next week, I want to go back in
and start writing again
because I don't feel like
I'm quite done writing.
And I think the writing process
has been incredibly exciting.
I mean, I love writing.
That's my favorite thing to do.